Yo ! que euh
je sais pas si c'est clair
que j'aimerais ça comme juste publier
des vidéos puis même s'ils sont pas
s que là je parle ça fait 54 comme c'est
pas bon en ce moment
je pouris la reprendre
mais en même temps Je
fa voir du volume. Il y a du volume qui
pas de la qualité de bon.
C'est bon tu sais pas tout
au final c'est bon.
Tu apprends
tu apprends. Fait que
au final oui c'est bon.
C'est mieux d'apprendre
en faisant
la quelque chose
que
de juste rien faire. Je pourrais juste
supprimer cette vidéo là en me disant
que
c'est pas pertinent ou juste j'étais pas
j'étais pas prêt à faire à parler de ça
juste la supprimer.
Alors que je peux juste la publier
qu'elle soit pas bonne de base parce que
là
je commençais avec de quoi c'était pas
clair, c'était pas bon mais là de ce que
je dis en ce moment c'est un peu plus
bon je c'est clair mais c'est ça
là c'est vraiment
un bon exemple de publier quelque chose
que même si c'est pas prêt publie pareil
parce que Ça revient à ce que je disais.
Tu es mieux de starter de quoi
qui est pas prêt
que de jamais rien faire parce que tu es
trop perfectionniste. C'est un des
points qui le plus souvent. C'est ça.
Ben dans la mar notre rencontre, c'est
que faut que tu fasses de faut que tu
lances de quoi sans que ça soit prêt.
Comme il y en a qui disent de je sais
qui j'ai oublié c'est qui mais qui
vendai un produit avant qu'il soit fait
fa tu vends rien et tu vend rien tu
vends qui est pas prêt tu vends quelque
chose qui n'existe pas
puis si au final
c'est extrêmement important parce que
sinon tu startes jamais tu as jamais
quelque chose qui est en traction tu as
aucune traction qui startte c'est la
traction qui fait que tuévolues puis tu
apprends.
Moi si je me rendais compte, c'est comme
les les entrepreneurs qu'on a parlé
pendant ces jourlà,
ça prenait tout plusieurs années avant
qu'il voient le fruit de leur travail
puis tout ça.
Mais fallait que tu tes à quelque part,
tu sais, fallait que tu commences à
quelque part.
Fa plus que tuattends en mode e je va je
vais travailler ça le plus parfait
possible pour que quand je le lance soit
parfait.
Ben first, il y a des chances que tu vas
jamais le lancer parce que c'est pas
parfait. Puis dans tous les cas, même si
tu travailles pendant full longtemps
pour de quoi qui est le plus parfait
possible, mais si tu le fais pas
attaquer, tu le fais pas confronter au
marché,
ça se peut que finalement tuas travaillé
pendant 2 ans de temps puis que
il y a aucune personne qui le veut.
Donc attaque le marché
les bo attaque le marché attaque ton
idée au marché le plus rapidement
possible teste réitaire
puis
le plus rapidement possible. Au final,
c'était oui tester les savoir les gens
ce qu'il pensent à ton affaire de ton de
ton produit, de ton service, de ton peu
importe,
mais d'avoir des gens qui sont prêts à
payer pour peut-être même une idée ou un
prototype qui est vraiment boboche mais
qui sont prêts à payer. Puis là, tuas de
quoi ? Là, tu peux dire que tu commences
à avoir une entreprise,
tu peux commencer à
te rapprocher d'entreprise parce que tu
quelqu'un qui est prêt à payer.
Si tuas pas personne qui est prêt à
payer,
tu as juste une idée encore que le monde
trouve belle belle belle mais sont pas
prê à payer. Tuas pas d'entreprise.
L'entreprise start quand tu as un
premier montant de e je suis prêt à
payer genre c'est où que je paye ? C'est
où que je paye ou genre he je sais que
tuas rien live mais je peux faire un
deal puis dans dans 6 mois ou dans peu
importe tu me lives la marchandise mais
je le paye plus tôt puis tu je change
sont prêts à payer excusez-moi ça va
bouger camé par que
c'est ça
pass à l'action M.